what do Americans do all day
the government's released its annual
look at how Americans spend their time
it's an interesting snapshot into the
daily lives of the average Joe or Jane
let's start with work Americans do
nearly eight hours of it on a weekday
versus five and a half hours on a
Saturday or Sunday across the entire
week that means nearly seven and a half
hours of work each day but 95% of
Americans have some time each day for
fun or what the Bureau of Labor
Statistics terms the leisure activities
in 2013 an ordinary adult without kids
at home spent four and a half hours on
these leisure activities if you add kids
into the mix that dropped to three and a
half but a hundred and sixty eight
minutes a day TV was the biggest time
suck in the land of the couch potato in
fact Americans only left their couches
to socialize with other Americans 43
minutes each day and if you're not at
work or watching TV or occasionally
doing some exercise you're either asleep
or apparently doing household chores on
a day that included chores the average
woman spent half an hour more on them
than the average man don't worry though
once you're retired it does apparently
get easier in fact if you're 75 or older
you spend around half your waking day in
2013 that's seven and a half hours
having some kind of fun reading
accounted for two hours of every weekend
for that same older demographic while 15
to 19 year-olds spent around the same
period of time
on a computer or playing games on an
average weekend those same American
teenagers spent just four minutes
reading a book the survey doesn't
mention iPads off campus